foreign
has made me feel this way before behind
me as many of you know is a bookcase
filled with frankly far too many manga
stories that artists and writers have
dedicated their lives to telling they
are the result of thousands of hours of
Blood Sweat and Tears being poured into
a passion project the likes of which
either I nor those who are even long
time fans can truly fully appreciate
when I started to review other series on
this channel outside of Dragon Ball I
preemptively purchased a host of other
popular series and since then have
expanded my collection to include even
more this is all to say that for years
this story Fullmetal Alchemist has just
been sitting behind me waiting for me to
finally find the time to give it the
attention that it deserved and now
having finally closed the book on the
final chapter of this breathtaking
series I find myself now glancing behind
me more and more at the stories I've yet
to read thinking just how many of these
are hiding masterpieces beneath their
covers but I digress how do I feel after
having finished Fullmetal Alchemist did
I think hiromo arakawa delivered a
conclusion worthy of this exceptional
and personal story what did I think of
Full Metal Alchemist what a question
[Music]
Frozen
[Applause]
I'm going to try my best to cover the
final seven volumes of manga I read this
week to bring this series to a close in
a satisfying fashion and trust me given
the amount of material I have to cover
this week make sense of break down and
give my thoughts on it'll be a miracle
if I do manage to make it to the Finish
Line without missing something someone
out there enjoys this is to say that
Full Metal Alchemist isn't a trite or
shallow work of art but instead one that
can be enjoyed by 100 different people
in 100 different ways and that's
according to the author herself so don't
shoot the messenger to tell you the
truth I've spent the last week
contemplating how I want to express
myself concerning this section of the
story this series and specifically how
it executed those last few chapters and
how they made me feel oftentimes in
these deep dives into a particular
author's work I like to dig into the
backstory of the Creator in question and
see how their lives might have shaped
the person they became and ultimately
the story they decided to tell and craft
in the same way Naruto was inspired by
kishimoto's own life experiences at
Hunter Hunter at times might have been a
reflection of gosh use inner turmoil at
the time I think Fullmetal Alchemist is
a projection of how a farm-loving
country girl in Northern Japan saw and
interpreted the world the more I read
about this woman the more I realized
that she's an artist in the truest sense
of the word a student not just of
drawing or traditional means but of
people she understands people she's the
sort of person to recognize her own
conviction and pursue a career writing
Shonen as a woman something at the time
and even today wasn't and still isn't
considered commonplace she's someone
that wrote her story with a clear
understanding that just like life
everyone who took the time to read this
story will likely Come Away with their
own unique impression and she welcomed
that much like the people of Jing and
her story she very much seems like the
sort of person not to talk in absolutes
but to feel the rhythm of the world or
the pulse of Her Own Story allowing her
characters to dictate the conclusions
without having Hardline bullet points
she needed to hit and it's that Nuance
that I believe takes this series from a
great Shonen story and elevates it to
one of the very best of all time without
question the seven deadly sins of this
story have been framed as villains from
the very beginning but in the end they
aren't in fact there really isn't any
Hardline villain or hero in this story
beyond that of the struggle between
virtue and selfishness and on the topic
of the sins are homunculi themselves I
very much liked how arikawa has chosen
to explore the nuances of them as not
only characters but narrative devices
themselves not pushing the portrayal
that they are absolute representations
of evil in this world but that they are
a reflection of our Humanity ourselves
that there are ways to express these
Desires in a positive fashion proving
that what makes human beings equal parts
special wonderful and terrifying is that
we all have the power to be evil or good
if we so choose greed as she points out
can be analogous to that of Hope wrath
can be channeled not to kill but to
instead incite change Etc and it's that
new ones that's permeated this story
that has in my opinion elevated it
beyond what it could have otherwise been
it's that realism those dark undertones
everyone loves in this story that I feel
stand and speak to the themes arikawa
has been trying to implement and express
throughout its run time and page count
gluttony and pride versus uh everyone
within many other stories this scene
might be considered again one of the
strongest scenes or fights offered in
its production but in arikawa's
Fullmetal Alchemist it's just another
day at the office while this is a rather
pivotal and intricate combat encounter
for Our Heroes with some genuinely high
stakes it's worth mentioning that even
the smaller scale encounters from this
story have offered a host of heart and
Imagination the likes of which I never
expected before picking this series up
contained within this fight while there
are certainly very obvious badass
offerings such as Al being manipulated
like a puppet by Pride as a
reunification of the two brothers the
nighttime setting offering a host of
unique opportunities to use lesser-known
skills like Ling popping out of greed to
say high-end of course the lion dude and
who could forget this
has to be like the single most edgy and
cool design in the entire manga and you
know I'm here for it while all of those
more obvious aspects are of course there
and I'm certain Millions have already
spoken about them at length already I
feel drawn to other areas like
gluttony's last words being that of lust
and looking back on this material now
for the purposes of this video after
having finished reading I'm happy I took
that note because it all matches
something I noticed much later in the
story that father okay okay I can't keep
calling this guy father that feels way
too pretentious so I noticed that Daddy
assembled a family of homunculi
gluttony's affinity for lust and her
relationship with him feels like that of
a mother and son Pride quite obviously
is another kid wrath is either a father
figure or a weird evil Uncle envy and
greed are clearly teenagers heck greed's
Last Words allude to him exhibiting
teenage angst and sloth is uh the dog
okay I don't know with that one it kind
of falls apart but I like to think
something like this was intentional
as we continue on into volume 22 with
this fight I noticed something that I
almost missed when I was reading through
it the first time and nothing was this
wonderful touch arikawa added to greed's
dialogue you might have noticed that
every time Ed refers to one of the two
chimeras in his dead he calls them
either lion guy or gorilla man or
something like that no matter what he
never calls them by their real names and
honestly at that point in the story even
I who takes notes didn't recall their
names either we just didn't think of it
as you know important however and this
is gorgeously subtle greed despite being
a debaterous outspoken blowhard doesn't
call them fake or derogatory names every
single time he refers to them by their
real names this creative Choice when you
focus on it almost feels like it's out
of character for greed Until you realize
that in reality it's pointing out that
greed isn't being entirely authentic
with what he truly wants it's a
wonderfully subtle indication of where
his true values as a character lie and
where his story will ultimately take him
I love this creative Choice with a
capital l it's just perfect Jeff's kiss
hoenheim and Al's plan is equally
amazing Al is an absolute Savage here
using himself as live bait to trap pride
inside the rocks with him and over the
last week I think I figured out what
makes Al specifically engaging as a
character for me for as long as I can
remember I've been a fan of active
characters characters like Luffy Goku
Vegeta Naruto Aaron from Attack on Titan
all natural leader types that take the
story by the horns control a narrative
and create interest for us as readers as
a result they all have wildly different
but natural charismas in other words
it's easy to enjoy those characters
because when they are on screen the
story happens Alphonse Elric is not an
active protagonist or at the very least
he's not a natural fit for one I think
Edward so naturally fits this
description however it's his will alone
that has caused this entire mess and
he's even the reason Al is there in the
first place the way he is time and again
he feverishly pushes scratches Claws and
crawls towards his ultimate righteous
goal and while Al certainly helps him in
whatever way he can he's always being
more inclined to worry about his brother
and insist they rest or exercise caution
in reaction to something or someone he's
a very natural reactionary character a
very likable one but why I like him as a
character case study so much is because
arikawa has written him to be a
reactionary character with a set of
morals that forces him outside of his
comfort zone to be active sort of like a
reverse Aaron Jaeger from Attack on
Titan if you will where Aaron was as
clear an active character as one could
imagine trapped in a world that reminded
him time and again that he was powerless
Alphonse is such a soft caring gentle
and kind reactionary character Taylor
Made for that role who is also trapped
in a world that forces him to consider
his actions more closely forcing him to
take the initiative and it's so damn
cool to watch and the plan they
Implement here in this section is just
outstanding
foreign
[Music]
this is a character that doesn't want
anyone to get hurt or die on his behalf
again and he is willing to shred his
body apart or separate himself from the
group for as long as he's needed to if
it means he's contributing to the goal
in a meaningful capacity to save others
he needs no food no oxygen so all he has
to do is pretty much wait for the day
to pass now it's a genius move in his
part I think and even if it ultimately
doesn't work out in his favor with pride
using Morse code to contact Kim the what
whatever the scene still rules and now
we're headed into the big finale as team
Mustang aided by Rebecca Maria Ross and
Havoc all make their presence known in
their own small ways I'm thrilled that
the moral of this story is not to let
your darker nature overshadow the good
that you can offer the world it's of
course already been pointed out in this
story that in every human being there's
the seven deadly sins of course that we
all fall prey to under the right and
wrong circumstances and I love that
throughout this story there's been a
consistent effort to not shy away from
each individual exhibiting their own
unique blend of either utilizing their
sin for good or avoiding the darkness
that they might flirt with entirely
we've seen greed use as a synonym for
Hope in many cases we later watch as the
pride of an entire civilization can be
the source of unity in hohenheim and we
see in the case of Al slothfulness can
also be seen as a willingness to rest
and enjoy the moment free of stress
Alphonse has tried to help his brother
unwind when he can and it's wonderful to
see on the other hand in the case of
Havoc he had every excuses sit in his
butt and just feel sorry for himself to
do so would be slothfulness taking over
his life in a counterproductive way and
we see him push past that in this scene
helping the war effort without which
they would have just suddenly lost this
is all to say that this is such a
stunningly tall Story full of detail and
nuance and oh it's a joy to read
foreign
[Music]
this is alphon's defining character
moment or at least the most demanding
one he's ever encountered in the past
I've spoken about how this story has
presented Edward and Winery with
circumstances that allow them to make a
character defining Choice a choice
demonstrating who exactly they are when
under extreme pressure the bigger the
antagonist and the easier the shortcut
the better for Winery it was deciding
not to retaliate against scar in violent
manner but to be true to her own healing
nature and for Ed it was choosing not to
take an easy but morally bankrupt Road
into achieving everything he's ever
wanted and in a completely different
fashion to that which Ed found himself
in one of kimlee's former henchmen
heinco or Lion Man offers alfons the
stone not to manipulate him but to
instead simply survive instead of
looking at this as a compromise the
Philosopher's Stone is presented as a
potential source for good here it's
explained that these people trapped
inside were unfairly sacrificed and now
as heinkel says there's a chance to
fight the same force that once took
everything away from them through
Alphonse Justice and Against All Odds in
this desperate situation Al moves
forward and uses the power of the stone
for the first and the very last time
resulting in one of the most astonishing
fight sequences in this story regardless
of whether it's the manga or the anime
and while this courage and determination
Alphonse demonstrates here will result
in another Reckless decision during the
climax of the story in chapter 107 it
also shows that this enormous power in
the right hands can be used to protect
and to heal and that is exactly how
Kimberly the one who offered Ed that
same Philosopher's Stone with evil
intentions is taken out by none other
than his former subordinate heinkel now
heals thanks to the power of that Fairy
Stone
foreign
[Music]
and as we continue reading Mustang's
forces Aid in the support of the
Armstrong agenda and hohenheim Scar
Edward and lanthan all rush in to
confront daddy until a teeny tiny small
wrench gets thrown into the mix
foreign
so yeah look these guys are all sorts of
scary and unsettling particularly when
you consider their moans the pleas for
help from an entire group of people
young and old so yeah it's the stuff of
nightmares however the implications are
both better and much worse than we might
consider upon their release in the story
there's a considerable amount of
Friendly Fires here with these little
foot soldiers eating up the higher-ups
but most importantly concerning her main
character Edward and his co-star scar
they're tasked with holding off these
Undead dolls but narratively to tell you
the truth these dolls are really just
here to keep our heroes busy waiting
until they're ready to join what is
possibly the best scene or conflict in
the entire tale it's easily one of the
most cathartic fights I've read through
in this story and honestly it might be
the best part of it and that might be
contentious but hear me out here I can
appreciate that given how many
heart-wrenching and truly inspiring
moments there are to come many have
their own Impressions that count as the
best but I chose this because I honestly
cannot remember the last time a series
so perfectly subverted the genre it was
hosed within using its own tropes luring
me in as a reader and forced me to learn
the same lesson as the central character
so effectively and succinctly I am of
course talking about Mustang versus a
suddenly freed and re-energized envy I
want to start off by addressing what I
think is the weakest part of this entire
encounter and that's the naivety and
gullibility this scene hinges on from
May I know I don't dislike the character
and it's not like it doesn't make sense
that she would be manipulated it just
always feels a little less clean of a
narrative pull when we rely on a
character's incompetence even if they
are a child and it does make sense but
if we excuse my understand for the
vertically challenged for just a moment
I want to closely examine what it is
about this scene that I think is so damn
effective once Envy eats all the
wood-ops in the surrounding area and
Mustang regroups by making the same Avon
Edward and Scar we finally get this
confession once Envy is cornered
so much of what makes this scene work is
rooted in character concerning Mustang
and his love for his friend yes but
additionally our personal Bond as
readers to both Mustang and indeed the
late Hues and it relies on our contempt
for Envy so much of the turmoil this
character Mustang's face has been due to
the coercive and murderous actions of
this homunculi and just like anyone in
his position Mustang erupts with both
figurative and literal fire Mustang
pursues Envy like as pyrotechnic Michael
Myers Envy tries to confuse Hawkeye
fails tries to prey on Mustang's
emotions fails I cannot express just how
cathetic this felt for me as a reader
for Envy to finally get what they
deserve now I'm about to make
comparisons to other popular Shonen
works by doing so I'm not trying to
suggest that one is better than the
other or that Full Metal Alchemist is
objectively superior what I want to do
is establish a trend or expectation set
up by prior shown in stories
because so much of what makes Shonen
successful predicates on its ability to
make us want to overcome that mountain
to either gain retribution or in this
case Justice Goku vs Frieza establishes
a villain that is truly reprehensible in
every sense of the word in the face of a
hero that does not want to kill but to
instead best him the villain pushes the
hero past the point of no return when
his best friend is killed before his
very eyes after which he is an audience
thirst for frieza's blood just like Goku
does and while the contest ends in Goku
showing Mercy ultimately the final
takeaway from this is that sometimes
there are people that aren't capable of
change individuals that ultimately lead
to their own defeat through the choices
they've made and Dragon Ball is filled
with these types of cathartic outbursts
by a hero having to overcome and defeat
or wipe out some kind of great evil and
look it's not just Dragon Ball Naruto
has this Hunter Hunter has this one
piece has this and for good reason it
leverages a tribalistic tendency in each
and every human being that reads the
material of course we want retribution
and justice for our lost friends and the
Shonen genre has used this trait we all
largely possess to grant us a
wonderfully cathartic payoff it creates
an expectation an expectation arakawa
decided to subvert at the last possible
moment
like many watching this scene while I
was reading through this I was thinking
yes yes yes destroyed that envious
bastard in my mind I'm thinking they
deserve it they are evil they've caused
so much trouble and they even killed a
character I personally loved in Hughes
for all intents and purposes Mustang in
this scene was exacting my revenge onto
this character for me and that's when
arakawa reminds us of the themes she
wishes to reinforce in this story Shonen
yes but with a healthy dose of reality
and realism for good measure and now we
notice that Mustang while acting as an
Arbiter of justice is additionally
consumed by a loss for revenge and wrath
Edward doesn't want to lose his friend
or rival to this darkness and alongside
scar warns him that there's a line he's
about to cross that he'll never be able
to come back from this is a wonderful
subversion of how traditional Shonen
stories play out and I think its
dedication to the themes in favor of
this less traditional approach made for
me e one of the most impactful scenes
I've ever read I just love that in the
process of making their way to saving
this country and the people inside of it
they are themselves the heroes
overcoming their own deadly sins that as
this story has already pointed out are
inherent to humankind and watching as
his dutiful and Resolute support in
Hawkeye being the main player in lifting
Mustang back from the brink It's a
Wonderful contrast to the stage she
herself was in towards the story's
beginning so in addition to a wonderful
subversion this scene also acts
partially as a payoff to three character
arcs in Mustang Hawkeye and even scar
who thinks to himself and alerts the
group to this mistake though all of
these characters still have more to
offer in this department and story and
speaking of philosophy and themes
hohenheim who I will henceforth refer to
as HoHo meets with Daddy one more time
they have a big long talk about ethics
in other words I don't quite know how to
define but look shh my sweet it is not
yet time to talk about ho ho or his
daddy scene
oh a tank that's pretty great and look
what's that it's Alex Armstrong and his
sister
that sounds like a poison that's a
girl's name and they are facing none
other than the brawn of the homunculi
faction the big old tired boy himself
we're talking about sloth
the fight here is pretty much the two
Armstrong siblings flexing what makes
them great characters with oliviere
really hope I'm pronouncing that right
uh with Olivier it's her strategy
cool-headedness and determination on
display with Alex it's his compassion
and late ability once he's fully focused
and honestly I don't know what else to
say to you guys other than I just really
enjoyed this fight scene I thought that
the way that they struggled against
sloth was compelling and honestly when
it came to how Alex Rose to the occasion
what his sister was injured it was just
icing on this wonderfully constructed
action cake and with that the Briggs
forces along with Armstrong have taken
control of squad A and C in Central and
in addition to that Izumi helps them
finish off sloth with her husband great
stuff and as a quick side I always found
sloth to be kind of hilarious like he
might have the funniest death in the
entire series like oh no I can't go on
it's too much effort to live I mean
that's kind of relatable and talking
about how tiring life is this dude just
gives off the same energy as this girl
people always ask me where I see myself
in 10 years like buddy I'm just trying
to make it to Friday
and in hindsight sloth might have been
my favorite after Greed for that very
reason sloth went too soon and with him
envy and a host of others now out of the
picture it seems the forces of good are
all successfully congregating in this
one location to fight for the greater
good it's a wonderful feeling but if I
know anything for one I know stories and
this is setting up the Hope necessary
for us to feel as readers it all be torn
away suddenly and in the process I'm
sure arakawa will reveal just how
powerful and in control the villain is
before the big finish or something I
know this is going to happen based on
convention but I am still oh so excited
to experience this regardless the magic
of gray storytelling arakawa take my
money just take all my money no not this
soon not this soon
Metal Alchemist
s
[Music]
this is not the face that I wanted to
see now or so I thought little did I
know I knew I definitely knew but little
did I know that this was the setup to
get more Peak combat for one of the best
writers in the industry arakawa and just
like I predicted moments before reading
it this dude takes all the advancements
and successes the forces of good have
achieved in his absence and with a few
swipes of his sword he totally wrecks
the tank on his own and offers more
pressure than the entire Central forces
combined and on top of all of that in
the middle of fighting wrath Buccaneer
just gets defeated take a big old nap on
the floor my sweet prince
I didn't hear no Bell but okay look I've
been kidding around but it's time to get
serious because unironically I adored
reading through this fight scene and why
because my boy or should I say boys here
greed and Ling doing their thing I've
said it before but I'm a sucker for a
great Andy hero and in the end greed
continues to redeem himself as he does
battle with wrath but wrath is honestly
Next Level and that's when Foo enters
the chat
now look there's some back and forth
here yes does food get to exercise some
anger towards the man that took his
daughter's arm yes does greed show some
awesomeness of course he does but look
this fight for me Peaks at one moment or
should I say an avalanche of story beats
that cluttered towards the end and it
all starts when food takes a death blow
from wrath like it's getting super
serious now one of the main Side
characters is now definitely not going
to make it and in response this greed
actually loses control of the body that
he's possessing and Ling erupts back
into control and once again mirroring
his last encounter with wrath crouches
before him clutching at his loved one to
protect them again unlike Bradley he's
someone that's never going to turn his
back on his people never and that's when
the unthinkable happened and really it
shouldn't have been Unthinkable I should
have seen it coming but this is just one
of those stories that gets me swept away
and that's really rare for me for a
story to get me to leave analytical mode
for a second or even for a scene is a
testament to how well constructed it
truly is but I digress Foo knocks out
Ling freeing up greed to once again take
control food pleads with him to harden
and to protect his Prince as he reveals
Dynamite hidden beneath the Garb that
he's wearing as he charges towards wrath
head on
sorry but can we talk about how great a
scene that is
come on
all right so things are going down Daddy
has his eyes on ho ho Ed Mustang Hawkeye
scar all arrive at the foot of the man
who created Bradley in the first place
this weird creepy doctor and all the
pieces are now set for the final
confrontation to end all confrontations
it seems and while I will be covering
that in just a moment I want to before
we move on give credit to the people who
helped to make this story and the one
that came before Oh So memorable it's
time to dive into the production and the
people behind Fullmetal Alchemist 2003
and Brotherhood
the anime adaptations
in part one of this review series I
spend time introducing the upper echelon
of both the Full Metal Alchemist animes
touching on the sheer number of high
quality Outsourcing Studios involved
along with bones's background in robust
Mecca animation leading to both series
featuring remarkable bottle consistency
but of course it's not buildings that
make anime it's people and there are
some key players that help to elevate
both series to insane Heights in 2003's
anime the most exceptional Talent on
board is a name that has become
synonymous with sakuga a name that even
those only with a passing interest in
animation no it is of course Yutaka
Nakamura
[Music]
foreign
over the past two decades Yutaka
Nakamura has cemented himself as the
father of modern action animation in my
mob psycho 100 Review I noted that
whether you know him by name or not
you've no doubt seen him in shows like
my hero Academia and one punch man and
going back further will open you up to
his iconic Cowboy Bebop work nowadays
you may well have seen scenes you
thought were him but were in fact just
inspired by his style those pencil
impact frames and cubes are so iconic
and so copied these days in 2003's
Fullmetal Alchemist anime he actually
joined the production late compared to
his peers at the time he was busy with
an anime called Wolf's Reign and while
his work there was solid it was nothing
compared to what he was about to produce
for Full Metal Alchemist while these
days his work is bombastic and defined
by Larger than Life set pieces his
approach back then was much more
grounded with an emphasis on intense
choreography over anything else one of
the best examples of this is his scene
of Edward vs greed I ludicrously well
animated fight that really demonstrates
nakamura's impressive understanding of
weighty motion and visceral timing it
vividly extends across the multitude of
pivotal scenes this man produced for the
series but it's not just exclusive to
action this man is capable of drawing
the most horrifying sequences of
morphing entities or fully realized
Dynamic environments he's truly an
animator with such a multi-faceted skill
set that it's honestly no surprise to
see why he's become such a pillar of the
industry after 20 years of refining
these skills year by year perhaps one of
his more interesting Feats on this
series comes from the show's fourth
opening that he directed boarded and
supervised while it features a whole
host of different animators the cores in
particular really demonstrates his touch
so well the way the camera dances from
character to character is just so
[__] good but of course Nakamura
can't animate every action scene and
thankfully the show wasn't strapped for
another star Nori mitsu Suzuki another
terrific animator that although may not
be quite a nakamura's level at this
stage in his career has since gone to
produce some absolutely ludicrous scenes
also how do you even begin to animate
backgrounds in vehicles like that it's
out of this world but that's not to say
that Suzuki wasn't producing some great
scenes for this show also he very much
was but with a very different emphasis
than nakamura's action Suzuki is a great
character animator by which I mean he's
incredible at drawing delicate movements
really bringing to life scenes that
aren't action necessarily and this is no
truer than an every ending animation
this Series has yeah you heard me right
Suzuki's solo animated every single
ending animation the 2003 Series has and
they are so damn good they really
showcased that actually he can do action
super well even if that's not where his
emphasis was in the episodes themselves
all the time but I mean he helped
Nakamura during the greed fight and
kicked ass with Ed vs multiform Envy so
he wasn't exactly totally locked into
just endings either this isn't to say
the 2003 anime was carried by only 2
people either by the way there are
absolutely other great scenes from
one-off animators dotted throughout but
Suzuki and nakamura's work are
definitely the two I think most fans
consciously or otherwise think of when
it comes to this series the show really
is a tremendous landmark of its time and
so it's crazy to think that Brotherhood
then came along and totally eclipsed its
production quality with one of the best
looking anime of all time where 2003's
anime had Yutaka Nakamura Brotherhood
had yoshimichi kameda an iconic figure
whose work is completely Inseparable
from the height of this series common is
certainly no stranger to those of you
who have watched my mob psycho review
comedy was the character designer there
and Rudy brought the series to life
through his trademark brushstroke style
it's an approach that can be found in
his incredible one-punch man animations
too but it's birth and usage that made
it so defining is all down to Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood
[Music]
thank you
it's really no exaggeration to say you
could do a 20 minute video on Comet as
Fullmetal Alchemist work alone it is
genuinely breathtaking in every sense of
the word greed versus Bradley is a
Powerhouse of Snappy timing and crazy
layouts I mean look at the way he draws
Green's coach at the start of this like
it's some sort of crazed bat creature or
the way he flourishes Bradley's face
with awesome brush Strokes or even the
last cut where he just throws away
traditionally painted backgrounds and
animates the entire room himself like
what a madman and that's just one seat
Mustang absolutely roasting the
ever-loving crap out of Envy has got to
be one of the most iconic scenes in
anime history common are just lets loose
with the most insane fire shapes topped
off with his now iconic brush Strokes
drenching the scene with unparalleled
energy I mean he really just never stops
firing on all cylinders across the
entire production Bradley versus Scar is
another one of those scenes of pure
unfiltered Madness it's all just so
Dynamic and when you look at arikawa's
panels from Stein versus lust it really
just feels like they were drawn with the
express purpose of Comedy bringing them
to life for all intents and purposes
kamida is Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and you can almost guarantee
that all of your favorite moments likely
come from him whether it's episode
content or opening and ending
contributions if you see Inky brush
Strokes it is more than likely his work
but as we know shows aren't really made
by one person alone and Brotherhood most
definitely has another huge player in
its lineup hirinoritanic has
contributions to this series are Beyond
Comprehension his output in the industry
across the years of 2008 and 2009 have
got to be the highest workload to ratio
ever seen by an animator and Brotherhood
alone this man was constantly putting
out multi-minit long sequences of absurd
quality when you consider most animators
are putting out 10 to 20 second long
scenes per episode and this man is
producing upwards of three minutes worth
of non-stop movement all by himself I
mean that kind of speaks to just how
insanely talented this guy is right his
work is defined by a few aspects most
most critically it's the wispy effect
and thin line work there's something
about it that just feels so effortless
in spite of its insane complexity he
also likes to draw on wins a lot which
means that every frame within a second
is a unique drawing which leads to a
level of fluidity rarely found in anime
he's a real multi-talented animator who
not only excels in human action but
draws the most random stuff so well like
look at this panda sneezing and then the
kids running across the screen it's all
animated so well and who teaches this
like he didn't learn this in school he's
just he can just he can just do this
this is the kind of animator Tanaka is
he gives it his all no matter what put
in front of him and his presence on this
series alongside comeda is a real key
factor in his position as one of the
all-time greats additionally Brotherhood
was truly blessed with a fantastic array
of guest animators too ryotimo a young
web animator produced one hell of a
sequence with Ling for example there was
also Takashi Kojima who many will know
from one piece these days who dropped in
for a short but awesome scene heck
there's kenotsuka a legendary Mecha
animator and big dragon ball fan who
popped up for another amazing fight it
really cannot be overstated just how
stacked brotherhood's production was
even if you put aside the sheer quality
of its storytelling its music and its
direction just the quality of its
animation alone could have it sit firmly
on top of all the best anime lists Full
Metal Alchemist whether it's the 2003
adaptation or its latest Brotherhood
take are some of anime's finest
Productions and what a thrill it was to
learn that a manga I have enjoyed so
much was blessed with two impressive
Feats of anime it's really no wonder you
guys have been yelling at each other
about which one's best for over a decade
now they're both so good
Full Metal Alchemist
so remember when I said that I knew
things were going too well and that
things were about to go bad again real
quick well I didn't realize just how
quickly that would happen and this
shouldn't shift Hit Me In Waves first of
all it was like who's that doctor dude
oh he did what damn that's bad then he
sends them away with a transmutation
circle double Jam then they appear in
front of Daddy triple damn and hohenheim
is inside of him oh kinky
please please think of the children I
think it's important to point out at
this juncture why I think this story
becomes ultimately as successful as it
does sticking a landing for a story no
matter its length is a difficult task it
just so happens that the longer the yarn
is spun or story in this case the more
complicated It ultimately runs the risk
of being towards the end
[Music]
R Martin famous for writing The Song of
Ice and Fire book series and of course
the series Game of Thrones was based off
of is experiencing that right now and
the TV show suffered immensely as a
direct result the first five or so
seasons of the TV show were directly
based off of the original work as George
had up until then written five books and
upon the release of the first season of
Game of Thrones he had already been
working on the sixth and penultimate
Edition in this series entitled The
Winds of Winter however that book has
been a work in progress for almost and I
kid you not 12 years this is of course
conjecture as I'm not spoken to George
myself or heard him talk about this
struggle in much detail but it seems to
me that he continued to expand his world
further and further into the books that
have been released beyond what had
originally initially been planned for
and this approach is honestly fine or at
least it is in theory do you see the
trouble arises when you establish all of
these plot lines and then you inevitably
need to orchestrate a way for them to
return and meet at a resolution
oftentimes meeting in a singular point
now with that said I hope I'm wrong that
George can indeed finish the sixth and
seventh books in a timely fashion but
I'm not gonna hold that much hope there
but my point is less about the specific
writing process itself and more the
nature of stories as a whole there is a
reason that most anime you will come
across are usually separated into arcs
constructing a congruent story with
adequate setup payoff characters and
themes for even a smaller story like
that is immensely difficult but what
Full Metal Alchemist shoots for is much
higher than that it is a single
continuous story that juggles a dozen
handfuls of balls in the air all at once
and with each passing volume I finished
as I progressed through this series I
wondered more and more how she could
possibly stick The Landing with such a
lofty Affair but the fact remains she
did arikala manages to not lose sight of
her Finish Line the whole way through
and make sure to deliver those playoffs
where she can as best as possible but
maybe what's most remarkable is that
while there is clearly a lot of thought
put into this series regarding its scene
structure dialogue and characters I
can't say this story does anything in
its ending that is revolutionary and I
love that she keeps it simple because
she already knows she's won us over as
fans at this point there's no need to
re-engineer the wheel or do something
pretentious or subversive at this point
because she knows that sometimes
sacrifice lessons being learned and
closure is a great ending in and of
itself and this story deserves that sort
of an ending like what happens with
Mustang being thrown into a portal of
Truth against his will to create a
sacrifice was a cool idea but it was
hinged on a rather simple concept
demonstrating how Mustang himself had
grown ethically as a human being he
wasn't going to throw his Humanity away
thanks to Hawkeye or even Al for
instance once again just like Ed was
tested at numerous points in the story
Al had the chance to get his body back
but upon realizing he'd be more useful
to his brother and friends as he
currently is he has to pass up this once
in a multi-year journey opportunity this
entire story is a Congregation of simple
ideas built on a foundation of
compelling and also simple themes that
in isolation aren't mind-blowing but
because arikawa was mindful she never
got confused and was able to paint a
very long story tying all of these kinds
of narrative tricks together and now we
find ourselves in a very cathartic spot
ready to witness the Day of Reckoning at
this point I'm thinking to myself this
is awesome but how the hell is there
still two volumes left to read like this
feels like the last scene but before I
give all my focus to the big final fight
I want to say that I love Scar's full
circle moment here where he surprises
wrath and all of us at home by revealing
new markings on his opposite arm
allowing him to reconstruct in addition
to deconstruct it's awesome and while I
never learn his name
in the end it really didn't matter
because at this point in the story he's
an entirely different person but that's
just one side of that fight and with
wrath arakawa added a really cute piece
of foreshadowing if you read this page
you'll see a shot of Wrath looking at
the sun commenting on the fact that it's
not God but the hand of man that they
must be wary of and when we cut back to
right now in this scene we have the hand
of man scar sing to wrath's end while he
looks at the eclipse it's a really nice
touch and while I love this it's far
from my favorite part
foreign
this is a small detail but the story
would be so much less without it it's
obvious that what Mustang did by denying
pride in the doctor's wishes to open the
portal to bring Hawkeye back was a good
morally Sound Decision but what's more
is it seems that because Pride had to
force Mustang to open the portal he in
addition to Mustang losing his eyesight
had something taken from him too and so
that choice Mustang made still has
helped the hero side despite their
current circumstances it's a lovely
metaphor for real life that while doing
the right thing might not benefit you
initially or directly there's a net
positive outcome that otherwise wouldn't
have been there had you taken the other
more morally dubious route and on the
back of that I just love how Edward
applies logic to the Jews that Pride
must too be weakened because of the
portal and in my mind I was thinking I
wonder if pride is using his
regenerative abilities over and over to
retain his current self to not let on
it's a really interesting set of
circumstances and a brilliant way to
weaken what has been up until now a
homunculi that was far too powerful to
deal with before
greed is the best character in the
series and I don't want to hear anything
about how cool Mustang is or how Noble
and funny Edward is or how endearing
Alice Reed is the only acceptable answer
here
trap ultimately set up by his creator to
get him out of the way and to Aid his
plan it's far from the last meaningful
contribution he's going to make to the
story for this might be my favorite part
of the big finish I alluded earlier to
the fact that greed doesn't talk down to
subordinates and in fact shows them more
respect than even the hero of this story
does and as the fight progresses we see
more and more just what sorts of wants
he's been denying himself trying to fill
what he believed was a bottomless void
of greed only to discover something far
more conventional before he meets his
demise but enough blabbering I'll get to
that later it's time after over 100
chapters of mystery and build up we
finally arrive at the true plan of the
monkey lie and Daddy not just a
Country-Wide Philosopher's Stone but
harnessing that power to entrap God
itself inside Daddy's body and man this
entire sequence really delivers big on
that whole bad things are coming soon
business I alluded to earlier 100
chapters of Adventure character growth
pain and Triumph all in service of
stopping whatever this dwarf in a bottle
was planning and then they fail daddy
knew the inner workings of his pawns too
well to the point of knowing how to get
greed himself in the exact position
needed to complete the process and what
follows is nearly an entire chapter of
watching on as an entire country is
erased from existence throughout this
entire story arakawa has done incredible
work in playing with the concept of
information in literature the idea of
the reader knowing more than the
characters is very common it's called
dramatic irony and it's often used to
great effect even within Fullmetal
Alchemist but what arakawa manages to
make use of so very often in this story
is well almost the exact opposite of
dramatic irony she seems to Revel in
having events occur that the reader is
not expected to understand in the
slightest at the time it's more than
foreshadowing its outright toying with
the reader's knowledge of the events
taking place making them feel completely
lost and In This Moment helpless this
sort of literary concept has been used
by arakal from the get-go too even as
far back as the initial events of Dr
Marco being ambushed by lust time and
time again we have been thrust into
parts of the world that at the time we
are not informed of in the slightest and
the revelation of these events are left
to the forces of time in hindsight the
final sequence of events regarding
Daddy's grand plan is the largest
culmination of this approach in this
story we watch in horror as this process
unfolds and over the course of a single
chapter dozens of bits of foreshadowing
and reverse dramatic irony all come
folding in on itself suddenly so much of
it now makes sense the anestris
transmutation circle the importance of
Al abandoning his body the Gathering of
the human sacrifices it all falls in on
this singular unseen objective of
absorbing God itself and what makes this
Revelation an approach double effective
and smart for me at least is that it
helps to place Us in the shoes of the
main characters if you think back these
two characters Al and Edward are not
just the main characters there are
full-on points of view you what they
know we know and we understand this
world and as much of this world as they
seem to know and while the story being
told is one part action the other part
is mystery and so it was a terrific
choice I think to have every Revelation
be as effective for us as it is to the
main Duo themselves and as I read in
horror while the unthinkable was
happening before me there was one major
piece of foreshadowing left the playoff
one element in this giant chess game
that had gone yet unaccounted for
hohenheim his trips around the land of a
mistress which before had served only as
moments of titillation around the
mystery of this character comes surging
to relevance as it is revealed that
Ho-Ho himself had been assembling a
contingency for this all along a
contingency that Daddy did not plan for
at all I find it really interesting that
the resolution to this doomsday plan
comes not only in the form of paying off
previous foreshadowing but chiefly as a
medium of ideological positing the
solution to this giant power struggle
doesn't calm in the form of who is the
strongest or even who planned the most
thoroughly it is a fundamental
deconstruction of the homunculus plan at
its core that maintaining the sanctity
and Order of life is far easier than
ripping it away Daddy was so very sure
that the 50 million souls in his
theoretical battery would more than
suffice against ho-ho's messy half a
billion but none of that matters because
as HoHo reveals to both Daddy and
simultaneously us as readers the soul
and body are intimately connected
removing that Soul by force is
considerably more difficult than
reuniting them and in hindsight we have
seen this at play so many times in the
story before Barry the chopper being
drawn to his body the chimeras or even
ALB being nearly dragged by force to his
body in recent chapters the two entities
are drawn together like magnets and all
it took was Ho Ho's planning and half a
million ancient Souls the shadow of a
solar eclipse and Decades of study to
bring the 50 million magnets colliding
back together then what an incredible
payoff it is really hard for this entire
video to not be just one big Full Metal
Alchemist payoffs compilation but this
story really does manage to resolve its
threads that satisfyingly and along that
very vein we finally get to see the True
Result of Scar and his brother's efforts
and I have to admit like many of the
other reveals that happen in these final
chapters I almost feel stupid in
hindsight not thinking of using the
Continental transmutation circle as a
base for a purification Circle feels so
obvious now that I think about it and as
scar opens the theoretical tap giving
the heroes a nearly Unlimited Supply of
power the real final fight begins not
just the takedown Daddy but to resolve
all of the remaining problems in a way
that is ethical and that's the key how
do you take out Pride without murdering
him how do you take out daddy without
harming others how do you get Ed and
Al's bodies back without resorting to
the tainted philosopher's Stones as the
entire cast charges a daddy with nearly
unlimited power now it feels like a
frantic rush to pop the balloon that is
him everyone is giving it their all to
bring Daddy to his knees even greed who
hey he calls him daddy too what did I
tell you greed is just the best anyways
this final push to the end of the Finish
Line really is all out you've got Daddy
retreating to the surface to try to
acquire more Philosopher's Stone him
setting off a small nuke worth of power
just to make a point the army shooting
its entire Firepower at that age just to
hold him off for a second Ronald's
McDonald's Mustang showing up with a
Hawkeye as is seeing ihawk greed
tricking Daddy into leaving an opening
by luring him in with his Philosopher's
Stone Edward having his arm completely
obliterated there is just so much that
happens in this final Sprint that is
impossible to cover in full detail
without talking for at least three more
hours and I'm not willing to do that but
one thing I can say for certain is that
the energy and Desperation of this
sequence shines through completely clear
here as a viewer and as a reader with
every single rapid fire turn of events I
felt more and more tense reading through
this gigantic Affair and then my heart
stopped because I could see plain as day
that Edward had permanently lost use of
both of his arms and I know that when Al
starts talking about using equivalent
exchange to sacrifice himself for Ed's
arm I know that arakawa is capable of
going through with it his entire final
fight has at least in part been about
the sacrifices the characters endure to
meet their end goal what is lost and
what is gained as a result Bradley is
taken down but at the cost of beloved
characters Mustang loses his eyes
rendering his incredible power almost
entirely useless and as I read Al's
words I knew in my heart that his
sacrifice for this cause would be seen
to fruition and while it indeed did it
certainly wasn't in vain Ed now with two
arms and a deep rage at the seeming loss
of his brother absolutely tears daddy
apart after several dozen characters
helped pull their weight in weakening
him Ed is finally able to pick himself
up and take this man apart and it is so
cathartic to read through we even get an
amazing call back to the very first
chapter of this story as Ed once again
declares get up you Third Rate fraud
I'll show you there's no comparison
between us even still the sacrifices for
this battle are not over as Daddy
finally begins to pop he lunges for
greed in a final attempt to sustain his
power and over the course of the next
few pages a genuinely heart-wrenching
conversation takes place between greed
and Lynn when in which greed is finally
able to come to terms with what it is he
sought the most from in life not wealth
not power not even God himself but
friends he abandons Lin or in reality
saves him and willingly sacrifices
himself inside Daddy to further weaken
him for the sake of his friends and I
will say it one last time I love greed
it is so crazy to me that this seemingly
unknown enemy we encountered briefly
near the beginning of this story has
managed to establish such a strong place
in the heart of its viewers and the
funny thing is looking back it's not
even really that greed has changed all
that much this isn't a Zuko or Vegeta
type situation where the bad guy slowly
learns the era of his ways and
transforms to a life of brewing tea for
orphanages I mean the greed we get in
the funnel volume is really not all that
different to the greed we initially mess
if anything it's more us as viewers that
have changed we were given time to be
with this person become acquainted with
their character traits and flaws their
own personal struggles and watch as they
slowly accepted who they were at their
core and with that final Act of
rebellion he leaves us with his yearly
final words of oh
[Music]
come on don't do this to me man all
that's left is a brittle husk of a dwarf
with a newly installed hole in his coal
chest but as Daddy dissipates away being
sucked back into the chambers of God
where he came from the biggest conflict
of all still isn't resolved is it Al is
gone and Ed still refuses to use the
Philosopher's Stone to bring back Al he
even turns down Ho Ho's offer to be the
toll to get out back so what solution
does Ed come up with in the end well he
gives up his portal of Truth his ability
to perform Alchemy altogether and that
tone might be the hardest possible
outcome to accept here it is the nature
of these kinds of stories the nature of
Shonen itself to grow attached to not
just the characters but to their
progression of power we feel a bond to
their progress and strength just as they
do we watch as these characters struggle
train overcome mountains achieve
triumphs and sacrifice themselves in
service of that progress so to see all
of that evaporate away in a single
moment well I think it might be harder
to swallow than Ed dying himself but
similar to Greed at his end Ed doesn't
seem particularly upset with this toll
despite everything he's been through it
becomes clear that Ed's incredible
Alchemy skills were never even the point
to him they were just a means to an end
a way to protect his friends as he
marched towards his goal of bringing Al
back and that's it that's the climax of
this entire long wonderful story All
That Remains is some falling action and
resolution about the sacrifices that the
characters made in this final battle
Mustang accepts the help of the
Philosopher's Stone in order to regain
his eyesight and help lead the land scar
is healed and accepts his place in this
new world we even finally get the
touching scene of windy crying tears of
joy as she sees Ed and Al whole again
not a single character is left
unresolved or unsatisfied but in truth
the main point of this falling action
that left the largest impact on B is
likely the single most incredible page
turn of this entire manga with Ed on the
roof of a house complaining about how he
wouldn't even need to climb up here to
fix the roof if he'd still had Alchemy
we turned the page to reveal an
absolutely breathtaking and rare
two-page landscape shot before him and
Ed sang to himself well I guess hard
work isn't always such a bad thing I
teared up when I read that it's such a
succinct and wonderfully fantastic
metaphor for the themes and motifs at
the heart of this entire story this
adventure I went on all 108 chapters of
it each one of them served a purpose not
a moment of these characters time was
wasted every friend they made hardship
they endured obstacle they overcame they
all served a purpose in helping progress
the world in a better Direction and they
sure as hell weren't all easy but that
didn't stop Ed or Al and the message of
the story is it should stop any of us
this has been a story I've wanted to
cover for years and like I said at the
beginning this has been sitting behind
me patiently waiting to be read all of
this time after all these years after
reading literally hundreds of volumes of
manga both in my leisure and on this
channel more and more it's becoming
difficult to ignore a certain level of
pressure and responsibility that comes
with covering a story like this one that
touches the hearts and minds of
literally millions of people across the
world and for those people those fans of
this story I never want to leave those
people down and in response to that
pressure my natural instinct is to throw
myself more into my work and with this I
absolutely did that across four
different videos and almost three hours
worth of material myself and my team
have tried to as best we can pour our
hearts and souls into this review for
all of you out there to enjoy it almost
feels appropriate to call this
Equivalent Exchange what you get out of
this is exactly what we put into it but
I'm also trying to deal with the rather
unhealthy relationship I have with my
work I think to myself maybe if I
tirelessly work people won't be
disappointed that's a feeling I try to
ignore in the back of my head during
every single video I've ever written
sometimes I succeed and make something
awesome and sometimes I don't and you
know I have to roll with those punches
too and while I still felt that same
pressure during this review series when
I turned that page to Ed patching that
roof I surprised myself with my reaction
to it I teared up I literally teared up
never has a manga delivered for me
something I never knew I needed like
that and it's not like I should have
seen this coming this story is after all
about perspective at the end of the day
three hours of time I've dedicated to
dissecting and expressing my thoughts on
your favorite story in this and it's
difficult but man was this wonderful to
read so to close things off with this
video I'll leave you with this it was
hard work reviewing this series but I
guess hard work isn't always such a bad
thing
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign